[Music]
[Music]
have you ever looked at a number of the
named and exotic equipment and weapons
and read the accompanying text and
thought what the hell does that mean
of course a lot of them are pretty
obvious
my personal favorite being the zero f's
chess piece
the text reads behold the field in which
i grow my
lay thine eyes upon it and see that it
is barren
which is probably the most awesome way i
can think of to tell someone that you
really just don't give a [ __ ]
but there are a number of others that
aren't quite so straightforward and
unless you have some knowledge on the
subject or take the time to look it up
they initially seem quite meaningless
however because i'm a nerd and can often
be found in my spare time traversing the
internet following wikipedia and general
website loops going down deep paths of
information trails on historical events
and people i personally found some of
this interesting enough to make a video
on
in 1925 aged 19 a farmer's son simul
hayoha began his 15 months of compulsory
military service in the bicycle
battalion in rivola v puri
it was noticed quite early on that semu
had the ability to estimate distances of
up to 150 meters with an accuracy of
around 1 meter
due to this simu immediately became
renowned for his sniping efficiency
it is said that he wants hit a target 16
times from 150 meters away in just one
minute
given that he was using a standard issue
bolt action rifle this was an
unbelievable accomplishment at the time
simu later became a sniper for the
finnish army during the
1939-1940 winter war between finland and
the soviet union
seymour was a modest man who never
boasted of his wartime merits
he really spoke of the war and his
experiences but in his own private diary
discovered in 2017 it gives detail on
what he called his sin list
where he estimates that the total number
of people shot by him to be around 500
in less than 100
days this figure alone would leave him
as having the highest number of sniper
kills by an individual in any major war
to date
seymour's reputation eventually earned
him a nickname the white death
and during the war the white death was
one of the leading themes of finnish
propaganda talking of an invisible
finnish soldier creating a hero of
mythical proportions
in 1940 seymour was hit in the face by
an explosive bullet fired by a red army
soldier
believed dead he was placed on a pile of
dead bodies
it wasn't until later when a soldier
noticed his twitching leg that he was
evacuated
the soldiers stated that half of his
face was missing
the bullet had removed his upper jaw
most of his lower jaw and the majority
of his left cheek
simul spent 14 months in 26 surgeries
recovering from his wounds
but as soon as he could he expressed his
desire to get back into the field and
serve his country in the continuation
war between 1941 and 1944
however due to the severity of his
injuries he was declined
sumo went on to make a full recovery and
after world war ii was given his own
farm in velavi where he would live until
his death in 2002
at the age of 96.
i'm a little skeptical on this one
because a couple of things don't quite
line up like the name but there are
certainly pieces of information that
follow the trend of other weapons
including the talent perfect lucky shot
which essentially means that any missed
shots returned to the magazine
thomas alexander baker was born on june
25th 1916 in new york
in 1940 he went on to join the army and
by 1944 he was serving as a private in
company a of the 105th infantry regiment
27th infantry division
on july 7th of that year baker's unit
came under attack by a large japanese
force
although he was seriously wounded early
on in the attack he refused to be
evacuated and continued to fight until
he ran out of ammo
when the comrade carrying him to safety
was wounded baker insisted that he be
left behind
his sole request was that he'd be
propped up against a tree and given a
pistol
this pistol had eight bullets remaining
and when american forces were able to
retake the position they found baker's
body the empty pistol and eight dead
japanese soldiers around him
after his death baker was promoted to
the rank of sergeant and on may 9th 1945
was awarded the medal of honor for his
actions throughout the battle
in september 1941 the london controlling
section or lcs was established
its goal to coordinate allied strategic
military deception during world war ii
after the beginning of the war the
allied nations began to recognise
deception as a useful strategy
the lcs was granted representatives from
all of the three services
and theoretically had a lot of power
but in reality there was little interest
in deception
they were authorised to prepare cover
and deception plans on a worldwide basis
coordinate deception plans prepared by
commands worldwide
and watch over the execution of
deception plans
the lcs brief cover and deception are
intended to create or reinforce a belief
in one's opponent which influences the
opponent's behavior along certain lines
cover induces belief that something true
is false
deception induces belief that something
false is true
cover conceals truth
deception conveys falsehood
cover induces non-action
deception induces action
the most significant operation with
which lcs was associated
was operation fortitude the cover and
deception for the normandy invasion in
1944
wyatt erp was an old west law man in
north america
in 1874 irp arrived in the boom town of
wichita kansas
where he was appointed to the police
force and developed a solid reputation
as a law man
but after a number of political issues
was later fired
erp began a path of moving from one boom
town to another
in 1879 he moved to tombstone where a
silver boom was underway
not long after he and his brothers
virgil and morgan clashed with a group
of outlaws known as the cowboys
the cowboys began threatening to kill
the earth brothers
this eventually led to a shootout near
the ok corral on october 26 1881
where the earth brothers killed three of
the cowboys receiving only
non-threatening injuries themselves
over the following months retaliation
attacks left virgil severely injured and
morgan assassinated
wyatt formed a federal posse which
killed three more cowboys whom they
thought were responsible
unlike his brothers wyatt was never
injured in any of the gunfights
which only added to his mystique after
his death
the chinese dragon is a legendary
creature in chinese mythology and
culture
it is a symbol of power strength and
good luck for people who are worthy of
it
historically the chinese dragon was
associated with the emperor of china and
used as a symbol to represent imperial
power
the han dynasty founder liu bang claimed
that he was conceived after his mother
dreamt of a dragon
the han dynasty ran for over 400 years
from 206 bc to 220 a.d
it was the second imperial dynasty after
the qing dynasty
the name lao is actually derived from
the liu family name
the period of which the han dynasty was
a time of invention and science
one of the most important inventions was
paper
others include iron casting crop
rotation and acupuncture
as well as advancements in medicine
mathematics building agriculture
engineering and astronomy
the silk road was also established
during this time allowing a great source
of wealth and luxury items into the
country
however when you look at the origins of
the han dynasty it can be interesting to
speculate on faye's true reasons behind
the dragon and the great significance it
has with her
especially given her current standing
dead or alive when it comes to the
betrayal of the division and the country
the han dynasty began with a peasant
revolt against the current ching emperor
it was led by liu bang son of a peasant
family
liu bang eventually won the war
and became emperor
this is obviously only a handful of the
named and exotic items out there but way
back when i originally wrote the script
i ended up abandoning it because i
thought it was something i was more
interested in than anyone else would be
plus i was starting to run the risk of
becoming a history channel with the way
it was going
but i recently opened it up again and
had read through and i still think it's
pretty cool i also love seeing the
nerdiness of some of the divs coming out
in these two
it's been a while since i've looked into
any of this so i may have a poke around
to see if there are any other items with
historical references that are worth
talking about
otherwise thank you very much for
watching and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]